hey everyone
welcome to this simply learn video on
communities full course
in this full course we will learn
everything about communities
in detail we will begin this full course
video with understanding what exactly is
kubernetes is
next we will see how to install
kubernetes and the differences between
kubernetes and docker
then we will look into the services and
components of cubanites in detail
after that we will be discussing
everything about the architecture of
kubernetes
then we will see how kubernetes can be
implemented on aws
finally we will conclude this video by
discussing the important kubernetes
interview questions and answers
for beginners and experienced candidates
by the end of this video
i can assure you that all your
communities career related queries
will have been answered so let's start
with an exciting video on the
configuration management tool
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit that bell
icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn
hello and welcome to simplyline in this
session we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you would
want to be using it within your devops
team
but before we get started remember to
hit the like button
if you like this video and the subscribe
button if you want to get notified about
more of these videos as they come out
and as always if you have any comments
about the content that we're covering or
questions that you have on the subject
please post them in the comments below
so let's get started we're going to
break up this presentation into four key
areas we're going to talk about
life before kubernetes which some of you
are probably experiencing right now
what is kubernetes the benefits that
kubernetes brings to you particularly if
you are using
containers in a devops environment and
then finally we're going to break down
the architecture and
working infrastructure for kubernetes so
you understand what's happening
and why the actions are happening the
way that they are so let's jump into our
first section of life
before kubernetes so the way that you
have done work in the past where you may
be doing work right now
is really building out and deploying
solutions into
two distinct areas one is a traditional
deployment where you're pushing out code
to physical servers in a data center and
you're managing
the operating system and the code that's
actually running
on each of those servers another
environment that you may potentially be
using
is to blame code out to virtual machines
so let's go through
and look at the two different types of
deployment that you may be experiencing
when you have applications running on
multiple machines
you run into the potential risk that the
setup and configuration of each of those
machines
isn't going to be consistent and your
code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime
and errors within the infrastructure of
your entire environment
there's going to be problems with
resource allocation
and you're going to have area issues
where applications
may be running effectively and not look
not effectively
and not load balance effectively across
the environment
the problem that you have with this kind
of infrastructure
is that it gets very expensive you can
only install
one piece of software one service on one
piece of hardware so your hardware is
being massively under utilized this is
where virtual machines have become
really popular with a virtual machine
you're able to have better resource
utilization and scalability
at much less cost and this allows you to
be able to run
multiple virtual machines on a single
piece of hardware
the problem is is that vms or for
virtual machines
are not perfect either some of the
challenges you run
with vms is that the actual hardware and
software need
needed to manage the vm environment can
be expensive
there are security risks with virtual
with vms
there are security risks with vms there
have been data breaches
recorded about solutions that run in
virtualized environments
you also run into an issue of
availability and this is largely because
you can only have a finite number
of virtual machines running on a piece
of hardware
and this results in limitations and
restrictions in the types of
environment you want to be running and
then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is time consuming
it can take a lot of time and it can
also get very expensive
so how about kubernetes well kubernetes
is a tool
that allows you to manage containerized
deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really
a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve
as deploying code in directly to
hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes
so let's kind of go through and look at
the differences between a virtual
machine
and kubernetes and we've got a few here
that we want to highlight
and you'll get an understanding of what
the differences are between the two
so first of all with virtual machines
there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
and this is largely because of
the legacy code the legacy of
kubernetes and where it came from we'll
talk about that in just a moment but
kubernetes is inherently secure
virtual machines are not easily portable
now with that said they
they are technically portable they're
just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with docker container
solutions it is extremely portable that
means that you can actually spin up and
spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it
on the demands of the customers as
they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few
other areas that we want to kind of
highlight from differences
virtual machines use much less isolation
when than
building out the encapsulated
environment
than kubernetes does for instance with a
virtual machine you have to
run hypervisor on top of the os and
hardware
and then inside of the virtual machine
you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast
on a kubernetes environment because it's
leveraging
a darker container and or container-like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware
and then inside of each container it
doesn't need to have that additional os
layer it's able to inherit what it needs
to be able to run the application
this makes the whole solution much more
flexible and allows you to run
many more containers on a piece of
hardware than versus
running virtual machines on a single
piece of hierarchy so as we
highlighted here vms are not as portable
as
kubernetes and kubernetes is portable
directly related to
the use of containerization and because
kubernetes is built on top of containers
it is
much less time consuming because you can
actually script
and automatically allocate resource to
nodes within your kubernetes environment
because it allows the infrastructure to
run
much more effectively and much more
efficiently so this is why if we look at
our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because
the demand for having more highly
scalable solutions that are more
efficient was just really a natural
evolution
of this software deployment model that
started with pushing out code to
physical hardware
and then pushing code out to virtual
machines and then needing to have
a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes
would have come about at some point in
time i'm just really glad it came back
when it did
so what is kubernetes let's let's dig
into the history of kubernetes and how
it came about
so in essence uh kubernetes is an open
source
platform that is allows you to manage
and deploy
and maintain groups of containers and
the container is something like
docker and if you're developing code
you're probably already using docker
today
consider kubernetes as the tool that
manages multiple docker environments
together now we talk a lot about
docker and as a container solution with
kubernetes the reality is is that
kubernetes can actually use
other container tools out there but
docker just simply is the most popular
container out there
both these tools are open source that's
why they're so popular
and they just allow you to be able to
have flexibility in being able to
scale up your solutions and they were
designed for
the post-digital world that we live in
existing today
so a little bit of background a little
bit of trivia around
kubernetes so kubernetes was originally
a successor
to a project at google and the original
project was google ball
um googleborg it does exactly what
kubernetes and
does today but kubernetes was rewritten
from the ground up and then
released as an open source project in
2014
so that people outside of google could
take advantage of the power of
kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
microsoft azure aws google cloud
all of them will leverage kubernetes and
it's just become
the the de facto tool for managing large
groups of containers
so let's kind of step through some of
the key benefits that you'd experience
from kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits
and the first it is highly portable and
is 100
open source code and this means that you
can actually go ahead and contribute
to this code project if you want to
through github
uh the ability to scale up the solution
is incredible
um what's um the the history of
kubernetes
being part of a google project for
managing the google
network and infrastructure kind of
really sets the groundwork for having a
solution that is
highly scalable the out of the high
scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient
and highly energized environment that
also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're
maintaining and it's really designed for
deployment so you can script out the
environment and
actually have it as part of your devops
model so you can scale up and meet the
demands of your customer
then what you'll find is that the load
balancing is extremely efficient
and it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across
your entire network so your network
remains stable
and then also the tool allows you to
manage the orchestration of your storage
so you can have local storage such as an
ssd
on the hardware that the kubernetes is
maintaining
or if the kubernetes environment is
pulling storage from a public cloud such
as
azure or aws you can actually go ahead
and make that available to your entire
system and you can inherit the security
that goes back and forth between the
cloud environments and one of the things
you'll find consistent with kubernetes
is that it is designed
for a cloud-first environment um
kubernetes as well
is that it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then
either restart the process kill the
process or replace it
and then because of that you also have
automated rollouts and drawbacks
in case you need to be able to manage
the state of the environment
and then finally you have automatic bin
packaging so you can actually specify
the compute power that's being used from
cpu and ram for each container so let's
dig into the final area
which is the actual kubernetes
architecture i'm going to cover this
at a high level there's actually another
video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper
into the kubernetes architecture and so
the kubernetes architecture is a
clustered-based architecture and it's
really about two key areas you have the
kubernetes master which actually
controls
um and all of the activities within
your entire kubernetes infrastructure
and then you have
nodes um that actually are running on
linux machines
um outs that are controlled by the
master so let's kind of go through some
of these um
areas so we look at the kubernetes
master uh to begin with
and then we'll start with uh etc
this is a tool that allows for the
configuration of information and
the management of nodes within your
cluster and one of the key
features that you'll find with all of
the tools that are managed within either
a the master environment or within a
node is that they are all accessible via
the api
server um and what's interesting about
the api server
is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually
secure each connection with ssl
and other security models to ensure that
your entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure
is tightly secured scheduler goes ahead
and actually as you'd expect it actually
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster
and then you have the control and the
controller is a daemon server that
actually
manages and pushes out the instructions
to all of your nodes so
the other tools really are the uh the
infrastructure
and you can consider them the
administration site um of the master
whereas controller is the management
actually pushes out all of the controls
via the api server
so let's actually dig into um one of the
actual nodes themselves and there are
three key areas of the nodes one is the
docker environment which actually helps
and manage
and maintain the container that's
actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api
server on the actual health of that node
and then you have the actual kubernetes
proxy which actually
runs the services actually inside of the
node so
as you see all of these infrastructures
are extremely lightweight
and designed to be very efficient and
very available
for your infrastructure and so here's a
quick recap
of the different tools are available and
it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node
the kubernetes master has the
instructions of what's going to happen
within your kubernetes infrastructure
and then it's going to push out those in
to an indefinite number of nodes that
will allow you to be able to scale up
and scale down
your solution in a dynamic way hi guys
in today's video i am going to show you
how to install ubuntu on kubernetes
kubernetes is an open source platform
used for deployment and management of
containers
so let's get started now the first step
is to install the necessary dependencies
using two
of the commands first is sudo apt get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password so
this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https
this is basically used to make
repositories via https so let's go ahead
with that
sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency
using the command sudo apt install
docker dot io
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker
we have to start and enable the docker
using the command
sudo system ctl start docker and sudo
system ctl enable dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation
the next step is we have to install the
necessary components for kubernetes
before that we have to install the curl
command because current command is used
to send data using a url syntax
let's install the call command using the
command sudo apt-get install code
so you have to select y and this will
take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that
sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it
using sudo apt key at and it's done
so the next step is we have to add a
repository in a certain location so
before doing that we have to change the
permission of that file so we do that
using c
or sudo c h mode command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead
and save this file in that location
first we have to
enter this command into the file
this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components
that is cubelet cubadium cubectyl and
kubernetes cni so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node
and to do this we have to first use a
swap off command
to disable the swapping on other devices
so let's do that sudo swap of hyperlink
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
cube adm init this is going to take a
few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done so moving forward
the next step is to deploy paths using
the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the
parts you have to use the command sudo
cubic till get pods
there you can see the parts that have
been deployed hello and in this video
we're going to cover
a common conversation which is
kubernetes versus
daca but before we jump into that i want
you to hit the subscribe button so you
get notified about
new content as it gets made available
and if you hit the notification button
that notification will then pop up on
your desktop as a video is published
from simply learn in addition if you
have any questions on the topic
please post them in the comments below
we read them and we do reply to them as
often as we can
so with that said let's jump into
kubernetes versus docker
so let's go through a couple of
scenarios let's do one for kubernetes
and then one for docker and we can
actually go through and understand what
the problem
specific companies have actually had and
how they're able to use the two
different tools to solve them so our
first one is with bose and bose
had a large catalog of products that
kept growing and their infrastructure
had to change
so the way that they looked at that was
actually establishing two primary goals
uh to be able to
allow their product groups to be able to
easier more easily catch
up to the scale of their business so
after going through
a number of solutions they ended up
coming up with a solution of having
kubernetes running their iot
platform as a service inside of amazon's
aws
cloud service and what you'll see with
both these products is they're very
cloud friendly but here we have
bose and kubernetes working together
with aws to be able to scale up and meet
the demands
of their product catalog and so the
result
is that we're able to increase the
number of non-production deployments
significantly by taking the number of
services from being
large bulky services down to small micro
services being able to handle as many as
1250 plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of
time and value has been opened through
the use of kubernetes now let's have a
look
at daca and see what a similar problem
that people would have so
the problem is with paypal and paypal
processes something
in the region of over 200 payments per
second
across all of their products and paypal
doesn't just have paypal they have
braintree and
venmo so the challenge um that uh paypal
was
uh really being given is that they had
different architectures
which resulted in different maintenance
cycles and different deployment times
and an overall
complexity from having a decades-old
architecture with paypal through to a
modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery
and be able to centralize the management
of all of the containers
with one existing group the net net
result
is that paypal was able to migrate over
700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over
200 000 containers this
ultimately opened up a 50 increase in
availability
for being able to and add in additional
time for building testing and deploying
of
applications just a huge win for paypal
now let's dig into kubernetes and docker
and so kubernetes is an open source uh
platform
and it's designed for being able to
maintain a large number of containers
and what you're going to find is that
your argument for kubernetes versus
docker
isn't a real argument it's kubernetes
and
docker working together so kubernetes is
able to manage the infrastructure of a
containerized environment and docker is
the number one container management
solution
and so with docker you're able to
automate the deployment of your
applications being able to keep them in
a very
lightweight environment and being able
to
create a nice consistent experience so
that
your developers are working in the same
containers that are then also pushed out
to production so with docker you're able
to manage
multiple containers running on the same
hardware much more efficiently than you
are with a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high
you're able to keep your applications
very isolated
the configuration for docker is really
quick and easy you can be up and running
in minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment
so we look at the deployment between the
two
and the differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of
pods and services in its deployment
whereas with docker
it's around about deploying services in
containers
uh so the the difference and here is
that kubernetes is going to manage the
entire environment and then
and that environment consisting of pods
and inside of a pod you're going to have
all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers that can
control
the services that actually power the
applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is
always available whereas a docker does
not and that's not surprising because
docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about
managing your infrastructure kubernetes
is going to
run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your
entire environment so not just one
container but
tens of thousands of containers whereas
docker is going to limit
the health check to the services that
it's managing within its own containers
now i'm not going to kid you kubernetes
is quite hard to set up it's it's
if of the tools that you're going to be
using in your devops environment it's
it's not an easy setup for you to use
and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services
within azure and other similar cloud
environments where they actually
will do the setup for you docker in
contrast is really easy to set up you
can
as i mentioned earlier you can be up and
running in a few minutes
as you would expect the fault tolerance
within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the
architecture of kubernetes is built on
the same architecture that google uses
for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure
in contrast docker has lower fault
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the
the services within its own containers
what you'll find is that
most public cloud providers will provide
support for both kubernetes and docker
here we've highlighted
microsoft azure because they were very
quick to jump on and support kubernetes
uh but the reality is
is that today google amazon and many
other providers are
having first level support for
kubernetes has just become
extremely popular in a very very short
time frame the company's using both
kubernetes and docker
is vast and every single day there are
more and more companies using it and you
should be able to
look and see whether or not you can add
your own company to this list
hello and welcome to simplyland today
we're going to be giving you a
kubernetes tutorial will
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content
from simply learn and as always if you
have any comments about the material
that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below
we do read them and we do reply to them
so with that said let's
jump in so we're going to go through a
bunch of things today around
kubernetes we're going to cover what
kubernetes is and why you should be
using it
along with the features of kubernetes
we're also going to take a little bit of
a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get
referred to quite frequently and then
we'll do a deep dive into the actual
kubernetes architecture itself and how
kubernetes runs and operates within your
network and then finally we're going to
look at some kubernetes use cases of how
you can actually apply
best learnings that other companies have
used with kubernetes we'll finish
everything off with a demo
where we actually step through and use
some of the actual
codes that you can actually use to run
uh from your terminal window
to actually activate kubernetes itself
so with that said let's jump in
so why kubernetes well kubernetes is
really
being built from allowing you to be able
to have a more
reliable infrastructure the tool itself
is designed to manage the containers
you have within your network it's very
modular in architecture which allows it
to be very
easy to be able to maintain and to be
able to scale
and meet the demands that your current
customers are offering you today
the actual ability for you to be able to
deploy and update
software at scale is really at the heart
and center of kubernetes is really one
of the reasons why kubernetes was
created was to be able to
scale up the deployment of software into
tens of thousands of
networks and servers uh within a data
center
and then finally uh when you start
working with kubernetes really what
you're doing is
laying the foundation for building cloud
native applications and
part of this comes from the architecture
and history of kubernetes which we'll
get to in a little bit
but it's good to know that as you're
using kubernetes and containerized
solutions that you're really building
out an infrastructure that's designed
for cloud-centric solution delivery so
let's dig into
why what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by google
google actually used the precursor to
kubernetes to manage and maintain
the data structure and data
infrastructure that they had within
their network
they really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that
google provided is that they uh
converted their code into an open source
program that they
released as kubernetes in 2014 and made
an open source
this means that any company can use
kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source
is that most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so
whether you're using microsoft azure
you're using google cloud or aws
you'll find that you can actually use
kubernetes and kubernetes and edit core
really helped eliminate manual processes
so it allowed for deploying and scaling
your container-based solutions much more
effortless within
a cloud environment so let's jump into
the features of kubernetes and
why you'd want to be using it and we
have a number of features that we want
to
kind of step through again the first
thing that kubernetes is a strong
benefit of is that it eliminates
those manual processes and allows you to
automate them
the benefit you have from this is that
you can then scale
up your automation across your entire
network so whether you are
managing 10 nodes within your network or
whether you're
managing 10 000 doesn't matter you have
the ability to scale
that something you simply didn't have
before kubernetes also will manage the
actual containers themselves um
including the security
and the storage and the networking
within those containers the great
uh benefit of working with kubernetes is
that uh not only is it a cloud-centric
solution but it was really
built from a core need of
a secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing
which really helps benefit any teams
scaling out containers
your kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have
nodes that have your containers the
health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated
back to the kubernetes environment so
that the entire environment is always
being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional
hosting and launching that needs to be
done uh kubernetes will
help you automate those manual processes
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an
automatic roll back again this is just
allowing you to have that
confidence that when you're deploying a
solution that
everything is going to work within that
environment and then finally kubernetes
will allow you to mount and add the
storage needed to run your apps so
whether you have storage such as a local
ssd
storage device physically on the
hardware
or if you're connecting to storage via
the cloud
kubernetes will allow you to access the
storage you need
how you're accessing it so let's look a
little bit into
the differences between kubernetes and
docker swarm
so if we just step back a little bit
kubernetes and docker often get
connected with each other largely
because kubernetes
manages containers and docker is really
famous
for creating the most popular container
management solution which is called
docker if you're a developer you're
probably already using docker today
so one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale just massive volume
of containers
docker swarm is docker's alternative
to kubernetes it's a tool that allows
you to also manage
large number large numbers of containers
um there are differences between
the two of them and right now without
doubt the most popular
um open source solution out there is
kubernetes from google
it just has a massive community behind
it
and the community uh really have
embraced um kubernetes um yes the
original product was by
developed by google but google has been
great steward and they've allowed the
community to drive
the future evolution of the product uh
docker swarm is actually managed
and developed by docker um there is a
smaller community but it is also a very
passionate community
and the reason being is that both
products are actually pretty good
and you just really kind of have to
choose which one you want to go with
without doubt there is
more customization and extensions
built for kubernetes simply because the
community is just so much bigger
than the docker swarm community but with
that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment
you will be able to set up docker swarm
very very quickly whereas kubernetes
does require some heavy lifting to get
up and running
now with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud
very often those environments will
actually set up
kubernetes for you so you don't have to
do it and you can actually then focus on
writing the instructions to maintain
your kubernetes environment uh
kubernetes um
has extremely high fault tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing
sites such as gmail google.com
youtube i mean just incredibly robust
environment compared to docker swamp
which has
lower fault tolerance um and this really
kind of leads into
um the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee
um strong clusters and management just a
really reliable environment
dr swarm however is able to take
containers and deploy them into large
casters very very quickly two
interesting differences
is that with kubernetes the load
balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes
matures that skill set uh in contrast
load balancing
is automatic within docker swarm so
let's dig
into the kubernetes architecture and
just kind of expose
some of those key elements um if you're
interested in actually having a very
deep dive into kubernetes
architecture we have already got another
video and
we should have a link in the comments
that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it
uses nodes to actually manage all the
individual
hardware within a specific unit
and so a node is really a physical
machine
in a data center or a virtual machine
and
when you're setting up an environment on
a cloud environment such as microsoft
azure or google cloud or aws
kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node
so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual
nodes but actually works with the
cluster as a whole and and why that's
important is that it's a
tool to manage your entire environment
it's not going to come down and manage
the individual node itself it's going to
match the entire environment
the actual control of data within a
cluster um it's very very flexible
within kubernetes you can have
local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that
cloud-based storage offers you is that
you are
increasingly moving your solution into
more of
a hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and
why that's important is that it gives
you the opportunity
to scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to
increase the hard drive space you can do
that very easily from the cloud whereas
local hardware is a little bit harder to
imagine great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from
and so the the next layer down is the
actual management of the application and
that's within a container and as
mentioned earlier
docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
docker
as it was a natural maturity from using
a virtual machine
but kubernetes itself will actually
manage the containers that you have
within your nodes and so you have a
collection of containers
working together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that pod so if a
container or a pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay
running and being efficient and so the
pots themselves
will actually be managed by kubernetes
and you really want to
let kubernetes do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
parts your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual
management of all the pods you have out
there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called
ingress and going back earlier we talked
about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where
you can use an external service but
still have that layer of security that
is vital for your solution because to be
able to provide the ingress connection
uh kubernetes requires an ssl connection
which um automatically allows for a
secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of
the actual architecture on the
right-hand side we have our nodes and
the pods within our nodes and within
those pods are the containers
on the left hand side we have the master
architecture and the master architecture
is the actual brains behind the work
that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for
all of the nodes and then at the bottom
left-hand side we have commands which
are written
on a local workstation and those
commands are pushed up
to the master so let's kind of dig a
little bit further into
the architecture of the master um so the
master itself
is uh comprised of a number of key
components um again this is the
tool that's going to manage your
uh entire kubernetes infrastructure the
key components that you have
are the etcd control manager
scheduler api server and the key
four components are etct or the cluster
store the controller manager
the scheduler and the api server the
cluster store is the tool where all the
details of the work that you're doing
is stored and it's going to manage the
rules going to manage all the
instructions and this is where
you're going to post that information
the controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that
actually controls when instructions and
tasks
are pushed out to all the pods and nodes
within your network
and then finally you have an api server
which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a
worker slave architecture and slaves are
all the different nodes and pods within
your network and so a part itself will
have
multiple one or more multiple containers
and then
each container and then each part will
have a docker container
a kubelet and a kubernetes proxy and the
these are tools to allow you to
communicate back up to the master layer
so the docker is the actual container
itself and this is going to actually
run your application and the
instructions here are to pull down
the correct container from the docker
images that you have within your library
the cubelet is going to manage your
containers and your container
instructions that will be
deployed to the cubelet are going to be
written in either yaml or json
format yaml is just great if you haven't
had a chance to start working with yaml
i certainly encourage you to do so it's
very easy to pick up
if you know any xml you'll pick up yaml
very quickly
and finally the kubernetes proxy is the
tool that interacts
with the master environment within the
kubernetes network and allows all the
instructions from that are pushed to the
kubelet and
to docker to be able to perform
effectively so let's have a look at some
of the companies using kubernetes
there are a lot and if you're doing any
work today in the cloud and
even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple work in the cloud
there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would
are probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are spotify
sap ebay and of course
some of the the big companies out there
google with their entire network of
solutions and microsoft with office and
their tools so let's take a
a step into a youtube now let's have a
look at a kubernetes use case
and in this example we're going to look
at the new york times and how
they use kubernetes to solve a problem
that their iit department was struggling
with
so when new york times started working
after their data centers their
their actual deployments were small and
the applications were managed across vms
but the problem is is that as new york
times became more of a digital company
they started building more digital
solutions
and at some point they realized that uh
what they needed to do was to
embrace the cloud and move all their
solutions to the cloud however
their first step of using the cloud and
this is i think typical for a lot of
companies is that they treated
the cloud hosted provider in the same
way as they would with a data center and
they
at some point they realized they had to
take a change and this is where the
development team
came in and they said look how about we
stop thinking of our solutions
as a data center even though they're
being run in amazon and start thinking
them as cloud first solutions and so
what they proposed and what they ended
up doing was using
google cloud platform with kubernetes as
a service um to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much
faster speed and in the world of digital
content speed is everything they were
able to reduce the time for deployment
from
minutes to seconds and by doing this
they were able to
increase the amount of time that uptime
for the actual
infrastructure um updates began to be
deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to
schedule an event when you do the
deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution
more portable so the fundamental end
line
for the new york times is that by
leveraging kubernetes they were able to
automatically
manage their deployments and scheduling
of solutions
instead of having to do solutions
through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times
website so let's finally kind of look
into some of the important terminologies
before
we take our time to do a demo so we have
six terms that we're going to look
through
and we'll let you uh read through these
but
we have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical
vertical in which applications are
managed and run we have a node
that are the working machines that run
containerized applications and other
workloads
there is the pod which is within a node
and is a group of containers that are
deployed together on the same host
we have replication controllers and a
replication controller is used to define
a
pod life cycle rather than to create the
pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources
labels are key value pairs that are
attached to objects such as parts
and the key value pair or the label can
be filter organize and perform
operations on resources replication
sets define how many replicas of each
pod will be running
and managed when you want to either
replace a pod when it dies
annotation is a label with much larger
data capacity
a name is a resource as it is identified
volume is the direction which data is
accessible to a container
namespaces provide additional
qualification to resources name and then
finally
service is an abstraction of a top-tier
pods which provide a single ip address
and dns name by which the pods can be
accessed so this time what we want to do
is take you through kubernetes demo
actually runs through
some of these basic controls so i'm
going to take you through a video of how
to actually
install kubernetes um and to use some of
the basic instructions
so kubernetes is the most widely used
platform
for container management the first step
is to actually install the necessary
dependencies so let's see if there's any
updates first
so the first so to check if there's any
updates we use the command sudo
app dash get update we're entering our
password
and this looks like it's going to take a
few minutes because we've got a few
updates that need to be running
all right we're done all right next
we're going to write sudo apt-get
install dash y apt
transport https and this will
install all the dependencies we need to
actually start
installing the solutions needed for
kubernetes all right that was quick
now we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that
is write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go to typo correct
that quickly
and put in y so vs and we
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download and
install docker off the internet
and it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start docker and
enable docker using
our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're
using so we're going to use sudo
systemctl
start docker and sudo systemctl enable
docker this will be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for
kubernetes and we're going to install
the curl command and then kubelet cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command
cubelet cubic c2 and cube adm
and so let's go ahead and put in the
sudo
apt-get install curl we're going to get
a prompt we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes
so the first what we're going to do is
we're going to actually put in the
kubernetes key so that's going to be
sudo curl dash
s and then we have a long url which is
https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc
apt dash key dot gpg
sudo apt dash key there we go
and create my typo there okay now we
have to go ahead and change permissions
of like
folder so we do that with sudo chmod
777 slash etc apt
sources.list.d all right we're good
okay now you want to go ahead and open
up your text editor
and we're going to make um an actual
edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in
is the following command db http
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
xenial main and we're gonna save this
file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then a
apt which is going to be down a little
bit
and there we have it and we're going to
save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file
as kubernetes.list and we'll save that
and then we can close out the notepad
and go back to the terminal window
and let's look and see if there are any
updates
again so we're going to go ahead and run
apt-get update
and it's going to run any updates from
what we've created
and we want to check what's in the
folder and so we do
cat slash accept etc
apt sources dot d slash kubernetes
dot list and there we are it shows what
we have in that text file
and so we're going to go ahead and we're
going to
uh install uh cubelet cubic cubic 2
and cube adm but first we're going to
have to initialize the master
i'm going to show you what an error you
would get if you
were to install cubelet um and the other
files too quickly
you get the following error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubexo
and kubernet cni and so we're going to
go ahead and use sudo swap
dash hyphen a and now we're going to
initialize
the master node and we're going to do
that with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to
initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the pod to a
network
and we have two commands that we're
going to use we use sudo cube
cube ctl apply and then
we have a long pathway to type out which
is
dash f https raw githubs
content.com koreo's final master
documentation cube dash final dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead
and deploy the nodes first so we're
going to do that by
now creating mkdi dash p
and then we have um dollar sign home
dash
dot cube we'll create that new directory
and
sudo cp dash i and then the path will be
uh etc slash kubernetes admin dot
conf and then dollar sign home slash
dot cube dot slash config and then
final one will be sudo
chown dollar sign open paren
id dash u close paren colon
dollar sign a brand id slash dash
g close paren dollar sign home slash
dot cube config all right now we're
going to go ahead and
deploy and uh let's see oh
yeah i think i have a typo in my command
here yep oh yeah
i did have a typo and so um i've
got that incorrect now so documentation
is actually spelled with a t not an s
and then we're going to go ahead and
we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic cube ctl
apply dash f and then we're just going
to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see
all of the parts that we have in our
network and so we're going to do that by
writing the command sudo qbec ctcl
get pods dash all dash dash name spaces
and it should list all of our pods we
only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to
so there's only one node so let's see
what we have here so we can use the
command sudo
you know cubic tl get nodes there we are
just one node
so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service
and so what we're going to go ahead is
deploy the
nginx as service and we're going to do
that with the command sudo
cubex ctl run dash dash image
equals nginx and we're going to put this
into
port 80. so it's going to be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80
environment emv equals uh ubuntu
open quotes uh domain equals cluster
close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl
expose deployment nginx dash app dash
dash port equals 80
name equals nginx dash http and once
we've done this we'll be able to then
run the command to actually
see our services and there'll be quite a
few of them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a there we have quite a lot of
lists
quite a lot of services listed so there
you are that's the
instructions on how to get docker up and
running and
uh with some basic commands and it it's
worth going through a few times to
get right um but once you actually have
um the kubernetes environment up and
running and managing your docker
environment and containers
it's extremely powerful if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
welcome to kubernetes architecture from
simply land we're going to take a deep
dive into
the kubernetes architecture if you're
new to kubernetes we already have an
introduction that goes
and provides an overview of kubernetes
and we have the link below
so you can go straight to that if you
want to have a refresher otherwise hang
around and join us in this
presentation and if you want to see more
of these videos hit the subscribe button
and if you want to get notified hit the
notification bell and every time we post
up a new video you'll get the
notification
right onto your phone or on your desktop
that the new video has been uploaded
and as always if you have any questions
please post them in the comments below
we do read the questions and we try to
respond to all of them
as quickly as we can with that said
let's jump into kubernetes architecture
so we're going to break out the
presentation to the following areas
we're going to cover what kubernetes is
and why you want to be using it we're
going to introduce the actual
architecture and provide an
overview of how it contains the
containers
and the other components that you'd have
within the architecture we'll also
compare kubernetes with docker
swarm and one of the things that you
hear with kubernetes almost in the same
breath as docker and we have to be
careful not to confuse
docker from a container point of view
and docker swarm which is
a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management tool so compare the two of
those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally
do a deep dive into the architecture of
kubernetes and provide
a case study of where kubernetes has
been used successfully in the past so
let's jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so
kubernetes is a tool that was designed
to actually help
manage and contain large groups of
containers it was developed originally
by google out of the google book
solution and then open source by google
the actual environment allows you to
manage
large groups of containers so if you're
a developer in devops
and you're working with docker then
you're used to the concept of a
container
and you'll also know that containers and
cloud
technologies tend to be almost breathed
in the same breath
so the work that you're doing with
kubernetes is to be able to manage
large groups of containers inside of the
cloud
the thing that's great about working
with kubernetes is that it
is incredibly flexible and allows you to
have incredibly complex
applications run efficient efficiently
so let's step into why you'd want to use
kubernetes so
a couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open source solution originally
developed by google but it is available
on most cloud platforms today so aws
google cloud
microsoft azure all of them support
kubernetes and what you'll find is as
you're setting up your infrastructure
particularly if you're using containers
you'll see that the support for
kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors
it's extremely um useful for being able
to
manage large modular environments and
that's really kind of
these i think one of the big benefits of
kubernetes is its modularity
is that it really breaks down uh
containers into their smaller parts and
once you do that it becomes much more
efficient for you as an administrator to
be able to manage that entire entire
environment
the reproductibility of kubernetes is
extremely high
you can build our infrastructures very
quickly and have them being able to
manage and have containers coming on and
off and
killed and created to be able to help
load balance your entire environment
and so again you know we keep talking
about containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are manage
through containers and being able to do
that in a virtualized infrastructure
and the thing that's also really good
with kubernetes is it's really easy to
deploy solutions
you just have to use a simple curl call
and you can actually push out your
kubernetes infrastructure so let's have
an
overview of the kubernetes architecture
so kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control
all of your nodes and and the node
contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so
consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods
i'm sorry infinite number of nodes are
being managed
by the master environment so you have
your cluster which is a collection of
servers that
maintain the availability and the
compute power such as ram cpu
and disk utilization and you have the
master which is really components that
control and
schedule uh the activities of your
network and then you have the node which
actually hosts the actual docker
virtual machine itself um and be able to
actually control
and communicate back to the master the
health of that
pod and we'll get into more detail in
the architecture later in the
presentation
so you know you keep hearing me talk
about containers but they really
are the center of the work that you're
doing with
kubernetes and can the concept around
kubernetes and containers
is really just a natural evolution
of where we've been with internet and
digital technologies over the last
10 15 years so before kubernetes
you had tools where you're either
running virtual machines or you're
running uh
data centers that had to maintain and
manage and notify you of any
interruptions in your network kubernetes
is the tool that actually comes in and
helps address those interruptions
and manages them for you so the solution
to this is the use of containers so
you can think of containers as that
natural evolution from you know uh
15 20 years ago you would have written
your code and posted it
to a data center more recently you
probably post your code to a
virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container
and everything is self-contained and can
be pushed out to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're they're
isolated environments
very easy for developers to work in them
but it's also really easy for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production
so let's kind of step and back and look
at a competing product
to kubernetes which is docker swarm now
one of the things we have to
remember is that daca containers which
are
extremely popular um built by the
company docker and made open source and
docker actually has other products one
of those other products
is docker swarm and docker swarm is a
tool that allows you to be able to
manage multiple containers so if we look
at some of the
uh the benefits of using docker swarm
versus kubernetes and one things that
you'll find is that
both tools have strengths and weaknesses
but it's really good that they're both
out there
because it helps keep it really kind of
justifies
the importance of having these kind of
tools so
a kubernetes was designed originally
from the ground up to be auto scaling
whereas docker swarm isn't the load
balancing is automatic on docker swan
whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure
load balancing across your nodes the
installation for docker swarm is really
fast and easy i mean you can be up and
running within minutes
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um i mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but
it's it is a tool that's when you
compare the two docker swarms much
easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable
and it's you know that's its real
strength is its
ability to have strong clusters whereas
with docker swarm its cluster stream
isn't
um as strong when compared to kubernetes
now you compare it to anything else on
the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison
but kubernetes really does have the
advantage here
if you're looking at the two compared to
each other for scalability i mean
kubernetes was designed for by google to
scale up and support
google cloud network infrastructure they
uh both allow you to be able to
share um storage volumes with docker you
can actually do it
with any container with that is managed
by the docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes it manages
the storage with the pods and a pod can
have
multiple containers within it but you
can't take it down to the level of the
container
interestingly uh kubernetes does have a
graphical user interface
um for being able to control and manage
uh the environment
the reality however is that you're
likely to be using terminal
to actually make the controls and
commands to control your
either docker swarm or kubernetes
environment and it's great that it has a
gui
and to get you started but once you're
up and running you're going to be using
terminal window for those fast quick
administrative controls that you need to
make so let's look at the hardware
components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light
of all the systems that we're looking at
is extremely lightweight
um it allows you to have if you compare
it to like a virtual machine which is
very heavy
you know kubernetes is extremely
lightweight and harder uses any
resources at all
interesting enough though is that if you
are looking at
the usage of cpu it's better to actually
take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes
because the nodes will actually combine
together to give you that whole compute
power
again this is why kubernetes works
really well in the cloud where you can
do that kind of activity
rather than if you're running in your
own data center um so you can have
persistent volumes
such as a local ssd or you can actually
attach
to a cloud data storage again
kubernetes is really designed for the
cloud i would encourage you to
use cloud storage wherever possible
rather than relying on
physical storage uh the reason being is
that if you connect to cloud storage and
you need to flex your
your storage the cloud will do that for
you i mean that's just an inherent part
of why you'd have cloud storage whereas
if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware
so let's kind of pivot and look at the
software components as compared to
the hardware components so the main part
of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running in the
container
runs on linux so if you um have docker
installed as a developer on your machine
it's actually running
inside of linux and that's what makes it
so lightweight
and really one of the things that you'll
find is that most data centers and cloud
providers now
are running predominantly on linux
inside of the um the the container
itself is then managed inside of
a pod and a pod is really just a group
of containers bundled together
and the kubernetes scheduler and
proxy server then actually manage what
how the pods are actually pushed out
uh into your kubernetes environment the
the pods themselves can actually
then share resources both networking and
storage
so parts aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually
managed through a layer of abstraction
and part of their deployment and and
this is the strength of kubernetes you
use
um to find your infrastructure and then
kubernetes will then manage it for you
and there isn't that
problem of um manual management of pods
uh if you have to manage the deployment
of them and you
that's simply taken away and it's
completely automated
and the the final area of software
services is on
ingress and this is really the secure
way of being able to have
communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster
and again this is uh done security
through ssl
layers and allows you to ensure that
security is at the center of the work
that you have within your kubernetes
environment so let's dive now into the
actual architecture before we start
looking at a use case
of how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is
um we looked at this uh diagram at the
beginning of the presentation and there
are really three key areas there's the
workstation where you develop your
commands and then you have your master
environment which
controls the scheduling the
communication
um and the actual commands that you have
created and pushes those out and manages
the health of your entire
node network and each node has various
pods
so we like break this down so the master
node is the most vital component
with the master uh you have four key
controls you have et cetera
controller manager schedule an api
server
the cluster store etc this actually
measures the details and values that
you've developed on your local
workstation um
and then we'll work with the output
control schedule and api server to
communicate that out
those instructions of how your
infrastructure should look like to your
entire network
the control manager is really an api
server and again
this is all about security so we use
restful apis
which can be packaged in ssl to
communicate back and forth um across
your pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well
so um at every single layer of
abstraction uh the communication is
secure
the schedule as the name would imply
really schedules um when tasks get sent
out
to the actual nodes themselves now the
nodes themselves are
are done nodes they just have uh the
applications um
running on them the master and the sperm
is really doing all of the work
uh to make sure that your entire network
is running um
efficiently and then you have the api
server which has your rest commands and
the communication
and back and forth across your networks
that is secure
and efficient so your node environment
is where all the
work that you do with your containers
gets pushed out too
so um a work is really a it's a
combination of containers and each
container
will then logically run together on that
node so you'd have a collection of
containers uh
on a node that all make logical sense to
have together uh within each node um you
have a
docker and this is your isolated
environment for
running your container you have your
cubelet which is a service for conveying
information back and forth um to the
service about the actual health
of the kubernetes node itself and then
finally you have the proxy server and
the proxy server is able to manage the
nodes the volumes
the the creation of new containers um
and actually helps pass the community
and they the health of the container
back up to the master to see whether or
not the container should be
either killed stop started or um updated
so finally let's look and see where
kubernetes is being used by other
companies
so you know kubernetes is being used by
a lot of companies and they're really
using it to help
manage complex existing systems so that
they can have
greater performance and with the end
goal of being able to delight the
customer increase value to the customer
and enhance
increased value and revenue into the
organization
so an example of this is a company
called blackrock where
they actually went through the process
of implementing kubernetes
so they so blackrock had a challenge
where they needed to be able to
have much more dynamic access to their
resources
uh they were running complex
installations on
people's desktops and it was just really
really difficult
to be able to manage their entire
infrastructure
and so they actually went and pivoted to
using kubernetes and this allowed them
to be able to be much more scalable and
expansive
in the in the management of their
infrastructure
and as you can imagine kubernetes was
then hooked
into their entire existing system and
has really become a key
part of the success that blackrock is
now experiencing
of a very stable infrastructure um and
the bottom line
is that blackrock is now able to have
confidence
in their infrastructure and be able to
give that confidence
as back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services
kubernetes specific to aws cloud
platform so what's
a part of this tutorial and demo what's
in store for you at
offset i would like to cover the basics
of orchestration tools
as most of you would know kubernetes is
one of the most popular orchestration
tools in recent times
specifically for applications which are
cloud native
and deployed on some or the other types
of containers
but what are these organization tools
why would one need to use orchestration
tools
what are the facilities or features
provided by this orchestration tools
that's the first thing that i'm going to
cover
after that i will pick two orchestration
tools
specific to container management docker
swarm
versus kubernetes i'm going to compare
them with regard to the features that
they provide the use cases that they
cover
what facilities that they provide and
when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kuvernez architecture
what exactly is required for setting up
a kubernetes cluster
what runs in a control plane or a master
node
what runs as a part of the worker node
after that
i will end the tutorial by running you
through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform
i will use something called as cops
which is one of the admin
tools for setting up production grade
kubernetes cluster so i will use this to
set up a three note cluster
on aws all right now that we set the
context right let me get
started so what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code
to your continuous integration to
testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production
managing your production servers the
dependencies that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware
the features of fault tolerance
self-healing capabilities auto scaling
all this has complicated over the last
few years
as a part of devops one thing that
everyone is interested
in is managing all this application
dependency
or lifecycle management using some or
the other kind of a tool so that's where
these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide
is you'll have to just let them know
what are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are
the fault tolerance mechanisms that it
has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required
if at all you can bake in all these
specific parameters into your tool
your orchestration tool becomes a
one-stop shop for
all your deployment and configuration
management needs
that's where this orchestration tools
have become a very very popular and
relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more
interested in adopting devops practices
all right so having said that about
orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools
specifically for container management
docker
swarm and kubernetes many of the
applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are
called or kind of fall into a category
of cloud native
where the application need not know much
about the underlying
infrastructure or the platform where
these applications are running
so these two along with apache missions
there are many other container
management systems
but i'm going to pick docker swarm and
kubernetes
for comparing the features that is
provided by
these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm
and kubuntes just because of the reason
that both of them
operate in the space of container
management they
do something very very similar to
containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools
however there's a big difference that
exists when it comes to
the types of containers that both of
them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be
used for docker swamp is a cluster
management solution
that is provided by docker container
docker
is one of the very very popular
containers of recent times
and in case you have your applications
that is totally powered by
only docker containers if you have a
need where you want to run a cluster
of servers which are running only docker
containers docker swarm should be
your choice for your orchestration tool
kubernetes on the other hand
can cater to any other types of
containers other than
docker and including docker as well so
in case you have your applications which
have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container
kubernetes should be your choice of
orchestration too
a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in docker
containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 60 nodes
docker swarm should be your choice of
orchestration tool
on the other hand kubernetes is
something that was open sourced by
google
and the kind of the scale of operations
that kubernetes can cater to
is google scale so if in case your
applications are more than a thousand
nodes
that is where kubernetes comes into play
that's the big difference that exists
between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside
let me compare docker swarm and
kubernetes
based upon other features which are
similar in nature the first and
important feature that kubernetes
provides
is something called as auto scaling if
at all the load on
your cluster is too high and your
application is experiencing
more load so kubernetes can add
new nodes to your cluster of course
you'll have to configure kubernetes in
order to
have those capabilities where it can
spin up new
vms or new nodes if at all you do that
configuration correctly
kubernetes has got the capacity or it
has got the feature
where it can bring up a new node and add
it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exist at that
moment
on similar lines if at all the load is
not too high
it can identify a few of those nodes
which have got less number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also
scale down by deleting few nodes from
your cluster
so that is the powerfulness of auto
scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist
in docker swamp the other feature of
load balancing
specifically application node balancing
so docker swarm gives you
an application level auto load balancing
however
kubernetes gives you the flexibility of
manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for
application load balancing installation
as i mentioned earlier docker swarm is a
loose
cluster of containers which are running
on nodes
it is very easy to spin up a new node
and then connect them
to a swarm and this can be done in a
very very loosely coupled way where you
can create swarms of your choice
notes are allowed to connect to swarms
and quit or leave the swamps on the fly
so
in and all the installation is pretty
easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node
how many masternodes how many config
planes that you want how many nodes that
you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes
strength is very very strong they are
very tightly coupled
and even they have the capability where
on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon
the requirement on a darkest form the
cluster strength is weak
as compared to copper days worker notes
can be added to a swarm
worker notes can be asked to leave us
form or can be taken out of a swarm
based upon the requirement so this is
kind of a loosely coupled architecture
for docker swarm
while kubernetes the cluster is very
tightly coupled
since docker swarm runs only docker
containers containers
find it very easy to share data a lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature
they are all from the same family so
it's very easy for them to share
not just volumes but lot of other things
however for kubernetes
since it manages containers of different
types
if your application has to share some
data across different containers there's
a little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your
containers to share data also when it
comes to kubernetes kubernetes groups
containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container
that's the preferred choice or multiple
containers and the idea of pod is like
each part can run in
any other node it's not guaranteed that
you would want to have two or three
parts
to be running on the same note that
makes data sharing a little bit of a
different thing compared to docker's
form uh gui
so there's not a good enough ui tool
in docker's form at least the ce edition
of it
which will allow you to get to know what
is running on your containers
what is the size of the containers what
is the volume of the containers and all
that stuff
there are some free and open source
tools like proteiner
which gives you a good visibility into
your running docker containers
however there's nothing at a swarm level
that is provided by
docker kubernetes gives you an out of
the box dashboard which is easy to
configure and set up
you can also club it with some metrics
services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this
across your cluster in a very beautiful
dashboard perspective
so that way um this is little bit of a
good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided
out of the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the
kubernetes architecture what comprises
of the kubernetes cluster what resides
in a master or a controlled plane and
what resides in a
worker node this is a very high level
depiction
of a kubernetes cluster so this is the
master node which has got
something called as a cluster store a
controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes
that are connected or administered by
the master node the master node can be
1 3 5 typically an odd number this is as
per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the masternodes to be in odd
numbers
so that whenever there's any contention
in terms of what needs to be deployed
where
or where to give the job to whom and
stuff like that all the masters would
cast their vote
and they would decide on the outcome so
that's the master node
and there are a bunch of uh nodes which
can be connected
and administered by the master node cuba
ctl
or the command from using which anybody
can
assign some workloads to the cluster can
also be
run either on the same node or on a
separate node so cubectl
is the command line tool that we will be
installing and using
in order to fire up our commands to our
cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out
any specific commands to my cluster all
this
is done using cuba ctl there's a bunch
of
rest apis which is used by cubicctl and
cubectl will talk to the api server
and fire up the commands specific to my
cluster
what runs in the master node master node
without saying
it's the most important component of any
of the cluster if at all you're running
um cluster with only one master node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can
talk to the different nodes in the
cluster so master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster
there's always one node that should be
running
as a master node that's the bare minimal
requirement for your cluster
so what are the other components in the
master node the most important one
is called etcd so this is nothing but
a data store a value of key value pair
which is stored
which contains all information about
your cluster so all the configuration
details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored
in the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything
else that has to be done specific to
your cluster
what's in the controller as the name
says controller is something
it's like a daemon server that is
running in a continuous loop
all the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas
the kind of workloads that is running
based upon the configuration that the
user has
set in so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers
endpoint controllers namespace
controllers all these controllers are
managed by
the controller component if any user
asked for some three replicas
of a particular pod or a service to be
running and if at all
any of the nodes goes down or the part
goes down for whatever reason
the controller is the one who wakes up
and assigns this particular job or the
part to some other available node by
looking up for the details using in the
cluster store that's the importance of
the control
manager or the controller the scheduler
the scheduler assigns the tasks based
upon
whoever has asked for any job to be
scheduled based upon a time
frame or based upon some criteria it
also tracks
the working load as to what what exactly
is the load who is running what and in
the cluster
and places the workload on whoever is
the available
resource at that time all right api
server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster
where how would the end user deploy
or give out any sort of a workload onto
your cluster
all the requests come to the api server
so this
is an entry point for all your um
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to
bring down a few services anybody wants
to put in a service
all this will have to come in as a part
of
a rest api endpoint and
api server is the entry point in case
you don't want
uh you know somebody to access your
cluster in case you want only specific
people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set
all those role-based access control for
this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick
overview about the master node what what
are the important components of a master
node now let's go over to what
runs in a worker or a slave node as i
mentioned earlier
slave nodes are something where the job
that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run
as a board as a service as a container
so in kubernetes world
there's something called as a pod a pod
is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper
around your running containers so slave
nodes or the
worker nodes typically run these parts
so that is where the whole
workload typically gets run but there
are a bunch of other components in the
in the node which also manages what runs
in the pod who has to have access to the
pod
what is the state of the pod is it in a
running state is it going down for some
reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over
those components that is there in the
slave node the most important component
in my opinion
that should be on the on the node should
be the container runtime as i mentioned
earlier
kubernetes can run any different types
of containers not just docker so in case
you want to have a node
which wants to have docker running on it
rkt running or
lkc running on it or any other container
environment that is running on it you
have to ensure that the specific
container runtime environment is
available on that specific node so that
whenever a job is submitted a
description of what needs to be run
as a part of the pod what should be the
image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be
up and running so that exists only if at
all the container runtime is installed
and running
on your kubernetes worker node okay now
that we know
what our kubernetes node can run how
would somebody assign
a job to our node that is using
something called as a cubelet as the
name says
cubelet or cubelet is a small subset
which
talks to the cube api server so any node
which has to
run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server
to the cubelet and cubelet is capable of
processing whatever job that is assigned
to it
and ensuring that so many parts and so
many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists
in the worker node is the cube proxy or
kubernetes proxy
this plays a very very important role
acting as a load balancer
and a network proxy so what typically
happens is whenever the pods are running
in nodes the parts can be typically
running in
any node there is no affinity towards
any node on which these parts are
running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere
so how would somebody reach out to these
applications
that is running in some pod which is
running in one container now and running
in probably another container
another node altogether tomorrow so that
is where your kubernetes proxy contains
a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts
and kind of connects the end points or
acts like a dns server
so that it knows when somebody is trying
to reach out to this
particular service which is the part on
which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by
acting as a load balancer and a network
proxy
now that at a very high level we know
what are all the components that
make up of our kubernetes cluster let's
go ahead and create a small cluster and
spin up this cluster on
aws platform finally we get to the demo
section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes
you also know at a very very high level
what are the components of a cluster
what is a master node or a control plane
what are the components of a
master node and what should be existing
in a worker node you're probably
thinking that it's maybe pretty hard to
kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo
of how to set up a simple three node
kubernetes cluster
using a tool called cops and i will be
doing this whole
setup on my aws cloud okay so what is
cops
cops is nothing but a simple tool this
is an admin tool
that allows you to bring up production
grade kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is
little challenging so that is why i
would use something called as a cops
and i will use this on my cluster which
i'll spin up on my
aws instance so i have an aws account
and what i will do first is
i will first spin up an ec2 server i
will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this
will be my starting point from where i'm
going to trigger
running up a big cluster in our case
i'll try to keep it little small i don't
want too many nodes in my cluster
i'm going to have one master node and
two worker nodes this whole operation
would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so
as you may know aws is little hard for
me
to programmatically run other components
or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create
an iam rule which will attach to my is2
server so that my ec2 server gets
powered with all the required role so
that it can go ahead and spin up cluster
based upon my configuration that i am
going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cuba ctl
which uh you would probably know by now
is nothing but a command line utility
using which i can
kind of connect to my cluster give it
some jobs put some parts and stuff like
that so i will use cuba ctl
i will also have a pair of ssh keys so
that
from this machine i would be able to
successfully get on to the master node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
begin
by first logging into my aws account
all the steps that i will be following
to bring up my
aws cluster kubernetes cluster will be
documented and i'll be sharing you
this document in a github repository so
that in case anybody wants to try you'll
be more than happy
to find all the required instructions in
one place okay
now the first thing that i would need is
to launch an
aws ec2 instance now this is an instance
where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to fire some
commands
which will bring up my kubernetes
cluster so let me log into my aws
account
and um let me stick to one particular
region
and let me bring up some a one ec2
instance
all right so let me launch my instance
let me choose
um doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire i would recommend choose fritter
only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
i don't want to change anything here
that looks good maybe i will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag
to my instance i will name this as my
cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
posts to be opened up so what i will do
is
i will create a new security group
called open
to the word i would not recommend that
you do this
since i don't want to it will take a
long time for me to specifically
uh to pick and choose um the ports that
has to be open
for running my cluster i don't want to
do that i will open up all the
http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp
i would say from anywhere just to be on
the safer side also open http
and https and i will make this anywhere
and anywhere this is good for me i will
say
review and launch all right so i chose a
t2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness i open up
all the ports
and um the instant details are you've
seen what is that i've chosen
all right now important part is like i
would need a key pair i need to create a
new keypad
i will call this as simply learn
keys i will download this keypair and
then i will
launch the instance it will take some
time for my ec2 instance to come up
in the meanwhile what i'll do is i will
convert i have this pen
file which is the pair of keys ssh keys
with which
i need to log into my ec2 instance so
i'll need to convert this because i'm
trying to connect from my windows box i
would need to convert this into
a ppk file so i have puttygen i'm going
to load
my set of keys here and convert that key
into
a ppk key all right open all right i
would say
save hang on save private key yes
i would say simply learn or simply
learn private private key and save this
here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file
and this is my tpk or my private key now
using the private key
i will log into my ec2 instance okay now
my ec2 instance is up and running it is
running in this
ohio region and this is the ip address
of my public ipads of my machine so let
me
connect to it so i use a moba x term
which is nothing but an ssh emulator
you can use putty or any of these
sessions which allow you to do an ssh
this is my ip address of my machine
and since i've spun up an amazon ami
the user this is the default user i
would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay
i am in my amazon ec2
instance so let me look at what are the
other things that i need to do
all right so as i said i just brought up
my ec2 instance
but i would need my ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket
where i'm going to store the instant
state of my kubernetes cluster
also some sort of an auto scaling group
because i want to spin up more and more
instances i also want to have
a private hosted zone using my route 53
so i would need my ec2 instance to have
all these sort of permissions for my
server so what i would do is i will go
and create
a permission a rule in the ec2 or
rather in the aws im role and i will
attach this
imrole to my ec2 instance
all right so let me go to my iam which
is nothing but the
identity and access management i will
create
a role called as possibly corpse role i
will create a role this role
will be used by my ec2 so i'm going to
click on ec2
and say next permissions they would need
a lot of permissions
uh specific permissions to be very
honest and the permissions are all
listed out here s3
ec2 and all this stuff just to keep it
pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a row name
i will say cubs roll for ec2 all right
so i'm going to create a rule
which has got administrative access
rules i'm going to create a role
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance
from which i'm going to run my cluster
would have all the prerequisite
permissions so that it can go and spin
up instances
talk to us three buckets and all that
stuff all right now let us
have our running instance get powered by
this role so i will connect this role
to my running instance all right so this
is my
easy to instant that is running i'll say
action attach
attach attach attach replace im rules
so there is no rule as of now i would
want my cops roll for easy this
row that i created so i want this new
room to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got
all the required permissions so that he
can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo
yam update iphone y so that
any of the because this is a newly
provisioned vm
i just want to ensure that all my
library system libraries are all updated
so that when i do install cop and cube
ctl and all those things
none of them will fail because of some
dependency or package issues
so i'm just running a sudo update iphone
y
so that all the libraries are updated
okay
looks like it is done so let me go ahead
and
install cops cops is a pretty simple
installation
it is available in a particular location
i have to just copy this
and ensure that i do a curl and i
install this particular stuff
all right so it is fetching uh the cops
tool is installing for me
once it is copied down let me change the
mode
so that i can execute it and then also
let me move it to my user local bin
so that it is available for me in my
path okay that's pretty much
the corpse installation let me also do
one other thing let me
install something called as cuba ctl so
this is what would be
you know a tool using which i'm going to
be firing my uh commands to my
kubernetes cluster once it comes up
right this is a pretty smaller
executable so
ctl all right so i have cuba ctl as well
as
cops installed on my ec2 server now okay
now what i'll do next is i'm going to
create an s3 bucket
in aws so that the equivalent is a
cluster state is persisted in this
bucket so let me create a simple bucket
with this name s3 bucket with this name
so let me go to
s3 and let me create a simple bucket
with this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so
the simply learn.kubernetes is the
bucket that i
created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster
let me now go and create a dns entry or
a dns zone
or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that
i'm coming up so i will create a private
hosted zone and possibility
possibly i will call this as
simplylearn.n so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other
public hosted zones in your name you can
always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have any one
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me
head down to route 53 click on any of
these and you'll get these
hosted zones out here so i'm going to
create a hosted zone here i'm going to
create a hosted zone
click on create hosted zone um this
would be
simply learn lot in i want to create a
public no i don't want
public i want a private hosted zone and
i'm going to associate my vpc
id for this hosted zone since i'm going
to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the ohio region for this
all right so this is the one that is
specific to the ohio region
so i will say this one i'll say create a
hosted sum
great now let me come back to my ec2 box
my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to
go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of
is that you know now that i put a name
for my cluster
i also have an s3 bucket that i've
configured for my cluster i will have to
ensure that i need to put in these two
configurations as a part of my cluster
building activity
so i will open my bash rc file and i'm
going to export these two variables if
at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is
nothing but the public sorry the private
hosted zone that i created
and the s3 bucket where i'm going to
create or rather i'm going to store my
cluster state so let me copy these two
and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these
and export them out as my variable i'm
going to save this here
now let me ensure that this gets picked
up all right i've got these two that
have configured
and i also ensure that these environment
variables are set
now let me create a pair of ssh keys
this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen
keygen i don't want to give any
parameters let it go to the home
directory with
the default name and without any
passphrase all right so i created a
bunch of my
keypair now i'm all set to go ahead and
run my cops
now cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster
the state of the cluster will be stored
in this particular variable which is
what
i have exported out the number of node
count is two
node count is the worker node count if
at all i don't specify configuration for
specifying
the master or the control pane as well
if i don't specify that the default one
is one so i'm going to create
one primary or the master node and two
uh
worker nodes uh size of my master node
size of the
worker nodes uh what are the zones where
i want uh this to be created
and where do i store the cluster
information and uh okay i've already
added this master account this
is actually not required but this is the
command that i'm going to fire off
so that i bring up my cluster all right
that went off
uh very fast but um this actually did
not create a cluster it is just the
definition of a cluster
and uh and that's why this came out very
fast
now that everything looks good with uh
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse
update cluster iphone iphone 8 yes now
this
will take some time a good 5 to 10
minutes for it to because this will
actually start provisioning the servers
and as i mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and two nodes or the
worker nodes
all right so this is the command for me
to validate the cluster and i'm going to
try it out first i'm pretty sure that it
will fail
because all my servers are not up yet
it is taking some time the validation
everything failed but
let me try to look at my ec2 instances
and uh see how many servers do i have
running as of now if you see
i had only one server that i had started
which was my cop server
and automatically the other three
instances one is called not start simply
not in
this these two are the nodes and this is
the master node
so these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran
all right so this may take a while for
it to get validated
a good five to ten minutes so what i'll
do is i'll pause the video now and i'll
come back
once uh the server the cluster is up and
running it's been a good uh
eight to nine minutes uh since i started
my cluster so let me
validate now okay seems good so there's
a master node
uh minimum one max one some nodes which
are nothing but
the slave nodes or the worker nodes
there are two of them due to micro
uh subnet so my cluster seem to be up
and running
and my cluster name is simply learn.n so
what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some
parts so let me get back to my
insta installation steps here the
validation cluster is done so let me
login to my since
my cluster name is simplyland.and this
is the way to log into my box
so let me get into my box so if you see
here this is the hostname
of the machine that i'm currently in if
you see this this is
nothing but our this cop server this is
the server now from here
i'm trying to get into the master box
all right so if you see the
ip address has changed i was in a
different box i'm in a different box now
if i see host name you'll find a
different host name so this is 153
which is nothing but the master node yep
it's 153 this is the particular host so
i'm getting into this machine now
so i started the cluster from my cop
server here it ran and brought up three
nodes so i'm actually getting into my
master node and see if i can run some
parts on it all right so let me try cuba
ctl
uh get cluster info try cube ctl
get nodes all right so there are three
nodes here master node and
um one master node and two worker nodes
so let me see if i have some pods here
cubic ctl gate pods so there's no port
as of now so what i'll try to do is let
me just pin up a very very simple part
just to check if my connections is
everything is correct or not correct
i have a simple node.js application that
i've built
uh and i've got a container for that
this is already pushed to the docker
i've registered is called simply learn
docker hub
and the image name that i have here is
called my node app
and i will use this image to power one
of my
ports that i will run so this is the way
in which i'm going to launch my pod
let me show you these commands cube ctl
run
the name for my deployment that i'm
going to run hyphen iphone image
and this is the image that is going to
be powering my container so this is
simply learn docker hub
forward slash my node app hyphen f1
replica is equal to i want two replicas
to be running and the port that i want
to expose this particular part is on 8 0
8 0. so let me run this as soon as this
is run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
um i'm not really interested in the
deployment i'm interested in checking if
all the parts are up and running so i
will say cube ctl
get bot all right so that was pretty
fast so i have two parts that are
running here these are two replicas
because i asked for two replicas these
parts are running so i can run cube ctl
describe pod pickup all right i can pick
up any of the pod name and see what is
the pod what is the information does it
contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image
name id this is actually running my
pod which is actually spinning up a
container great so far so good
so in kubernetes the pods can
are ephemeral so they can be there at
any time cannot beat any time if i need
to
expose my pot outside i will have to
create a service for my pot
so what i'll do is i'll create a very
very simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment
before that let me check cube cdl get
deployment so there's a deployment that
is created the deployment name is simply
run app so i will expose my deployment
simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i'm not specifying what
type and all i don't want to get into
the complications of
uh what are the different types of
exposing the service and all that stuff
so if i don't specify anything uh it
gives me something called a cluster ip
so this is where my pod is actually
exposed
so let me just check if at all this part
is up and running i'll just try a simple
curl command
curl http colon this is my cluster ip
and the port is 8080 if at all i had
this it's actually
hitting my application and giving me
whatever
i put a simple uh sys dot out kind of a
thing where i'm just
printing um the container id of whatever
pod is serving
uh being sold out of so i'm actually
hitting my container and i'm getting
this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running uh so let me just go and
clean it up
i'll say cube ctl uh delete deployment
simply learn app this should get rid of
all the parts that i created cube ctl
gitmod all right these parts are
intermediating things let me just check
cubectl
get services there's one service i don't
want this service let me delete that
keep ctl
delete service i want this all right
that sounds good so let me come back to
my
host my cop server from where i'm
running so i managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and
complete this demo by going and uh
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes
all right so this will ensure that it
will clean up my complete
cluster that i created so i had three or
four running instances if you see that
all the three are shutting down because
you know the cop server which had cops
installed on it uh has now got a mandate
to go ahead and
shut down and clean up the whole
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my
deployment hello and welcome to
kubernetes interview questions
now the great thing about being a
kubernetes expert is that there is a
growing market for people wanting to
hire you and you're going to get asked a
lot of questions
in this video we're going to take you
through the 13 most common
questions that you are likely to be
asked in a kubernetes interview
as always if you like this video we have
the subscribe button below
and then the like button that will
notify you of all
new videos as they get submitted also if
you have any questions feel free to post
those into the questions below
and we'll get back to you with answers
we're trying to answer as many questions
as
possible so without any more hesitation
let's jump into some of the popular
interview questions that you're going to
get asked we're going to break up the
interview questions into three
categories it's going to be beginner
intermediate and advanced um the
beginner questions are really going to
cover about three quarters of the
questions that we're going to ask here
and then the intermediate and advanced
will finalize out the
will finish out the final quarter and
and the reason is is that
quite typically most interviews um
you'll be
asked you know intermediate to beginner
level questions
mainly beginner level questions just so
you can demonstrate your understanding
of kubernetes
and then there's always one advanced
question that gets thrown out
just to make sure that you really do
know what you're talking about and
you've done at least
one or two kubernetes environment uh
setups to be able to validate your
experience
so let's kind of jump into that first
section which is you know why is
kubernetes widely used
and your answer to this really comes
into the fact that kubernetes
is widely used because of three distinct
areas one
is that kubernetes is an open source
platform that is
readily available for the management
containers and allows you to manage the
deployment scaling and management
of those containers and so the first
area is that it allows you for easy
deployment of your containers
the ability to scale effectively within
kubernetes not just
vertically but horizontally for your
containers and then finally the
kubernetes environment itself was really
designed
to make it easy to manage containers um
in
small parts other key areas of why
kubernetes
is popular is that kubernetes is the
single largest open source project
out there since its launch in 2014 is
just grown in leaps and bounds
around that project there is just a huge
community both
an online and physical community there
are just
a large number of online groups that are
supporting
kubernetes and allow you to get fast
access to information but in addition to
that there are
also a lot of local meetup groups
that cover specifically kubernetes
whether as part of a devops group or as
part of a dedicated kubernetes group
the actual environment itself is a
really robust way of being able to
manage your containers containers are
becoming the most popular way of being
able to deploy cloud-based applications
kubernetes is an effective and
persistent storage environment so
kubernetes is also able to effectively
manage
persistent storage whether it's local
storage as a
ssd drive or a local hard drive or
whether it's cloud-based storage
and because of the way that kubernetes
architecture is really designed for the
cloud from the ground up so it's a great
way to get started
in building out your cloud solutions and
then finally
the actual tools within kubernetes are
designed to help and
manage the health and monitoring of the
environment itself
so what is google container engine so
the google container engine is another
open source solution but it's designed
for
managing the docker containers and
clusters and so kubernetes
is a container management solution and
docker
is the most popular container solution
out there and this is just a way of
being able to bring the two
effectively with into each other so that
you can have docker
containers manage the application and
then kubernetes manage
the scale of your applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
the difference between kubernetes and
docker and this is important because
kubernetes and docker are often dropped
in the same
sentence and there's a lot of people
that get confused between the two
so fundamentally kubernetes is about
taking pods which contain containers
which have applications in
and deploying them at scale across a
cloud network
docker is the container solution itself
so the actual application itself is
put into the docker container because of
this difference
kubernetes is designed for auto scaling
it's highly available
whereas docker simply isn't because it
doesn't have to worry about that within
the container itself
the kubernetes environment will check
for liveness and readiness
of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with docker it's
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes
is complicated to set up it's really is
just simply complicated setup
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services will actually do the setup for
you whereas docker is very easy to set
up the
as you would expect with a tolerance
ratio there is high fault tolerance
river kubernetes whereas with docker is
low fault tolerance
again this is fundamental in the two
different types of
strategy that kubernetes and docker have
they're both
connected tightly with each other but
they both do different things
so what are the notable features of
kubernetes um one
is the ability to do container bands
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within
its entire network within the pods and
with its infrastructure
the services are managed for security
network and storage
uh it is self monitoring so it goes in
and is able to
check its own nodes for health and the
containers within
the nodes so it makes sure that the
applications are always running
effectively
you can do the scaling effectively both
vertically and horizontally within
kubernetes
the solution is open source so there's
no actual fee
for the actual kubernetes service itself
and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does they
mean by storage orchestration now
storage orchestration is that
you're able to access and share
either local storage such as a hard
drive or ssd
drive or a cloud-based drive and
my preference is always to go with
cloud-based drive because then you're
really positioning your solution to be a
true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes oh well you get
automatic rollback for changes that go
wrong
the a you're able to automate a lot
of the processes that would have been
manual processes previously
you're able to scale the resources both
vertically and horizontally easily and
quickly
and then the these three areas the
rollback
automating role bank automating services
and being able to scale
indirectly allows you to save money by
reducing the amount of time and people
working on your operations environment
so let's break out the architecture of
kubernetes so you're going to be
explaining us to explain um how is
kubernetes
architecture structured and there are
three key areas there's the application
layer there's kubernetes layer and then
there's the infrastructure layer we're
going to start
off with the infrastructure layer and so
the infrastructure layer is our base
layer and this is where all your where
you make your clusters for your
collections of storage and networking
resources within kubernetes and
this is where you would have if your
databases
are your data stored locally on a hard
drive or
in the cloud your core network and the
vms that you'd be building out your
infrastructure on
these allow you to group many machines
together into
a single unit so that you're able to
scale up and down very easily
to meet customer demand so let's talk
about the middle layer which is the
kubernetes layer now so if we're looking
at our architecture for our kubernetes
layers really broken down for the
the core operating system the docker
container environment
and the kubernetes code itself and this
is where you're able to
take machines and pull them together as
a cluster so that they work within that
kubernetes system
you have a master controller within the
kubernetes that
actually then will go ahead and manage
that the scheduler
control manager the api server and then
you'll be able to cluster
all of these kubernetes together so that
they're all working and processing as
one
single unit and then finally let's look
at the application layer where
you actually have your apps and so the
application layer
where you have your pool and your
services you know kubernetes will use
api to connect in and out of this layer
it's to run your applications within
containers and you use instructions
that are written in yaml or json to
actually
set up those containers and you actually
have the environment running on a plan
that examines these
instructions so it keeps the entire
environment healthy api ecosystem is
used to
interact with the cluster it's so you
don't have to
do that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the apis are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system
and so you have your schedule and
control manager actually
from the kubernetes environment doing
the hard work and then the workers
themselves
execute the the commands that are coming
from kubernetes
so you will be asked to kind of dig into
some of the key areas such as
explaining the master node and listing
its components
so the master node is comprised of four
key components there's the
cluster store the controller manager uh
the scheduler
and the api server so four key
components
remember four fingers four components
and then you're gonna be asked to
maybe dig deeper into what is a cluster
within kubernetes and so a customer is
really a combination of
resources such as machines into a single
node
and then those nodes are pulled together
and work as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
cluster and then
once you're actually working with that
whole cluster if
a node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers
in kubernetes and there are five types
of control manager uh you have the node
controller
the service account the token controller
the endpoint controller and the
replication controller and so the node
controller controls and handles the node
in the system the service account
enables access controls in the system
the token controller cleans up any
tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint controller joins services in
pods to the endpoint
objects and the replication controller
manages the port lifecycle
so what is the role of the cloud
controller manager within this
environment
and so the role the cloud control
manager is really to
help manage persistent storage and so
persistent storage uh
is storage that's either local storage
to the physical machine such as an ssd
or hard drive or cloud-based storage
and this allows the storage to be shared
across the entire
network what is the role of the cube api
server and the cube
scheduler so the cube api server
responsible for the extension of
communication between the kubernetes
nodes
and the master components and and it
does this through the
through apis the apis themselves are all
commands that are
rest based commands and it implements an
interface which means different tools
and libraries can
communicate effectively with each other
so what is the role of the cube api
server and the cube scheduler so the
cube scripture
actually does the distribution of work
across the entire infrastructure
to the actual um yaml scripts that
you've written are executed
appropriately at the right time so
you're going to be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume
is just a place where you can store data
again this can be
local data as in a hard drive
local to the physical machine or it can
be cloud-based
data so what is a cubelet and a cube
proxy so a cubelet is a service
responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
itself
the process and the q proxy itself is
responsible for maintaining the work and
the standards within the node
server in addition uh every node in the
cluster runs a simple network proxy and
q proxy routes requests to the correct
container
in that node in addition you'll have
some basic and primitive load balancing
and management of the node from the
proxy itself and there's additional
layers of management that get done
outside the proxy but the proxy is also
there to help
do some localized load management so
what is cube ctl so cube ctl
is your command line or terminal window
interface that allows you to
execute commands and later uh in this
video we'll actually go through some of
those commands
etcd is the store that configures the
details and essential values such as
key value pairs that are distributed
across your entire
network it also manages the network
rules and the post forwarding of
activity
so what are the disadvantages of
kubernetes well the first is it's really
hard to install and configure and this
is why
azure and many cloud services such as
google cloud
will actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you
it does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes
it is not simple to manage the service
you actually have to have a lot of
experience
and this is why people get paid a lot
for kubernetes skills it's a difficult
environment to get up and running
and be effective in that management
again kubernetes is just not an easy
platform to
learn it takes a lot of time and effort
and
one of the disadvantages is that uh
while kubernetes itself
is free because it is an open source
project getting the people who are
skilled you to
using kubernetes is expensive all right
so those were kind of the
introductory questions that you can
expect to be asked in your interview
the next set of questions are really
going to be on an intermediate and
advanced
level and these are the questions that
will be thrown out you know
you see these as being the trick
questions but you're really there to
test that you have the skill set
to be able to implement and manage
kubernetes within
a company so what happens if a master
node fails what happens if a worker node
fails
how would kubernetes manage that well
kubernetes is really designed for this
kind of scenario
and so you can actually look at it and
the response would be is that the part
itself does not get affected uh
kubernetes will actually respond and
fix the the failed node whether it is
uh needs to be repaired whether it needs
to be restarted or needs to be replaced
so what is a service role in kubernetes
so a service role is an abstraction for
all the pods it provides a virtual ip
address that allows clients to connect
to containers running in the pods using
that virtual ip address and the command
that you would use to get that with
you some of these cube ctl commands it's
quite a simple one
it's cube ctl get services and you get a
full
list then of all the services that are
available so how do i do a rollback
in deployment and so there's a couple of
ways you can do the rollback and the
first is if you want to see the rollout
history deployment
you would write cubectl rollout history
deployment and then
in square brackets deployment if you
want to just restore to the previous
rollout the command would be cubectl
rollout
undo deployment and then in square
brackets deployment and that would take
you back to the
previous deployment so what is an
ingress
controller so an english controller
really is a part that manages that
inbound traffic and a prominent feature
of that traffic
is that it is secured with an ssl
termination and so what we're going to
do
to now address some of the key ways in
which you can provide
api securities on kubernetes and we have
eight of those
so the first four are implementing
tl tls for your security the second
would be
api authentication the third is to make
the cubase protection the cubeless
protected via authorization mode equals
webhook
command the fourth is to monitor rbac
failures the fifth is to remove those
default service account
permissions six would be to filter
egress to cloud api
metadata apis the seventh is to use
pod security policy to restrict
container
policies and protect the node and the
eighth and final is to keep the cube at
the latest
version all right let's go into some of
the more advanced
commands and so the advanced questions
you're going to get are all going to be
commands that you're going to be asked
to write now
my advice for you for these questions is
to make sure that you have some of these
basic commands
memorized um they don't have to be
perfect when you're in the interview
environment but it's good to be able to
get up to a whiteboard and actually
write out what these commands
are just so you can actually demonstrate
that you know what the commands are
the interviewer isn't going to ask you
questions on
how would you apply kubernetes to the
company that you're
being hired for because you simply don't
have that knowledge but they do want to
be able to see clearly that you
understand
the commands and terminal window
instructions that will be able to
demonstrate how
you would actually go in and access some
of that information so one of the first
questions you might be asked is how do
you package kubernetes applications
and so you would use the package manager
within
kubernetes to be able to manage to pl
and configure and deploy applications uh
into your cluster and so here we have
the uh the helm command
that you would use so what are init
containers
and any container gets executed before
any other containers can run on the pod
and so you want to be able to illustrate
what the init instructions would look
like and here we have an example
and i would again use this example and
maybe memorize it for when you have this
question come up in your interview so
what is the difference between a config
map and a secret and these are more
uh fundamentals so a config map just has
the instructions that are clearly
available in plain text
on what the uh cube is supposed to do
whereas
uh the secrets are actually encrypted
and these are
like uh passwords and other sensitive
data that you don't want to have
easily available these are encrypted
information have to be
decrypted to access the content so if a
node is tainted is there a way to
schedule the pods to that node and
the answer is no there isn't and so what
you have to do then is schedule the pod
to be
fixed and so that schedule the pod to
fix the tainted node to
allow for tolerations to that and we
have here
the example code that you would use to
do that so how do you deploy a feature
with zero downtime in kubernetes well
kubernetes is designed to be able to
roll out
um applications with zero downtime and
here we have
four examples using the rolling update
as a strategy for
zero downtime uh deployments in
kubernetes again
memorize one of these so you can
actually illustrate how you use rollout
to be able to deploy
a zero downtime solution so how do you
monitor a pod
that is always running and so to do that
you use the liveness probe to
check the health of the application
within the pod
and see whether or not there are any
failures or whether or not the pot
itself
needs to be restarted so how do you
drain traffic from
pot during a maintenance so again um
this is a simple command for you to
remember
but to be able to drain an application
so that it's easy for you to be able to
do maintenance on the application
you would use the cube ctl grain and
then in square brackets the node name
and that would then uh temporarily drain
uh
that particular part so you can actually
do maintenance on it
what you have to then and this would
probably give you bonus points with your
in an interview is then reference the
uncorden command
so that you can uncordon the actual
node itself so that the part itself can
come back up into life
and work as a fully functioning solution
so to be able to tie surfaces to a
positive to a set of parts is that you
can apply labels
to the actual parts themselves and then
use the labels as selectors
to be able to glue surfaces to that pod
and again we have here an example of how
you'd actually do that
and again this is one of those where you
can probably won't be
asked to write this out but it'd be good
to have this memorized
how would you get all pods on a node and
so the following command will actually
go ahead
and bring all the pods into a kubernetes
cluster um this is quite
lengthy and you know maybe you want to
like talk to
how this would be done but we have the
instructions on how to do that right
here the important part is to make sure
that
you are when you're talking about the
node name that you
reference to whoever you're interviewing
that you would
what you would switch out to reference
the actual nodes that you're
trying to pull together into the
kubernetes cluster so how do parts mount
nfs volumes and so in these examples
here we
actually define the nfs server and then
the pod and how you'd actually mount two
together and again
uh what you want to be able to do is
illustrate why you would use
yaml and how you'd actually then point
to specific
ip addresses within your kubernetes
environment
within either the production or test
environments to be able to illustrate
how you would mount
up those nfs volumes and with that we
have come to an
end of this video on kubernetes full
course i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team of experts will be happy
to solve all your queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here
you